I don't know what that mean yeah so I
want to welcome you as well and in this
first session we thought we'd asked
Prakash to give us a talk about
semantics for physicists as we call it
there's a broad spectrum of people with
various backgrounds here and semantics
really emerged as Samson just said from
logic through computer science mainly in
programming language semantics
understanding how that that works
doctor II lecture would be useful for
those who not don't under have never
encountered semantics for let me let me
put it that way and with that I'm going
to turn it over to Prakash who's going
to give his third lecture in six days or
something all right
so I hope the title doesn't sound too
condescending that means one talks down
to people so so I think the reason why
Samson selected me to give this talk is
because I once used to be a physicist I
got trained in quantum field theory that
was what my dissertation was about and a
few years after my first postdoc I
changed to computer science and I
remember running into one of my physics
colleagues who asked me so what are you
doing in computer science Fortran
programming and I said no I'm actually
doing theoretical computer science and
he looked at me puzzled and he said what
on earth could that possibly be you
study ideal spherical computers
so this is not what we do in any case
right from I jumped into programming
languages right at the outset and was
introduced to the joys of semantics so I
thought I would tell you a little bit
about it so in essence this is really a
warm-up talk for Gordon Plotkin who is
going to really say something about
compositionality in programming
languages and I thought it would be
useful to give some kind of setting the
stage in some way so that you understand
what the aims and goals are turn it on
ok so what is it that we're trying to do
both Samantha cysts and physicists we're
both trying to describe the evolution of
a precisely specified dynamical system a
program is indeed a dynamical system the
great thing about programs is that they
have this completely static aspect
namely the text and then they have this
much more complicated dynamical aspect
namely the program in execution often
called a process and this relationship
between kind of the structural
properties of the program and the
dynamical aspects of the process have
been kind of the heart of semantics and
in that sense that shares a lot of
similarity with physics which is also
about writing down some kind of precise
model of a system and then studying its
evolution and other attendant properties
associated with its dynamics so I
created this table which summarizes
points of similarity and difference so
in programming semantics we have
importantly a precise syntax one spends
quite a lot of effort articulating this
syntax and there's our precise
formalisms namely some kind of inductive
definition stylized in some fashion to
spell out exactly what are the legal
acceptable programs and in the early
days of programming language research a
lot of effort went into the study of
syntax the algorithms to recognize when
things were legal or not this research
was so successful that it killed itself
nobody really does research in syntax of
grabbing languages anymore for very few
people because we have now such good
tools and many of the things that we
used to spend effort doing before are
now automatable so we have a precise
syntax but more importantly we have
semantics which is what happens when you
run these programs the execution effect
of these programs and this can be given
in a variety of ways so in the old days
there were other baroque formalisms like
the so called Vienna definition language
and other such ways of specifying what
happens when you run a program on some
kind of abstract machine so this usually
told you things like as you step through
the program what happens to the state of
the machine as it executes and the big
problem with this was precisely that it
failed to be compositional so in the
late 60s and early 70s under the
leadership of Dana Scott and Christopher
stretchy and then others a mathematical
approach called denotational semantics
was developed and I think the one of the
key ideas behind it was to actually make
reasoning about these programs
compositional programs are somebody has
said the most intricate largest
artifacts constructed by humans in terms
of number of moving parts so to speak
and the only way one has any chance of
understanding these things is by
understanding the pieces and
understanding how they are put together
now this phrase how they are put
together means what algebra is involved
in combining these things to produce the
composite okay so the the denotational
semantics approach was precisely to try
and go away from this very detailed
step-by-step operational description and
give a more mathematical abstract
description which as I said one of the
key points is to be compositional now
another thing that emerged from the
friend of work in semantics was the
concept of type which before had been
sort of thought of as a feature that one
had to address but it really became a
central idea in organizing how
information is organized think about the
type structure and
to understand that there were things
like higher types programs that took
other programs as arguments and indeed
returned other things programs as
results let's look at the corresponding
things in physics so indeed there is a
precise formalism so in fact more many
of them for example if you study quantum
field theory there is a fairly precise
formalism that goes with it along with
some murky backwaters but more or less
precise but one doesn't spend a lot of
time worrying about the nature of the of
the syntax or this or indeed the
semantics it's kind of implicitly taken
for granted that it works like this but
that's starting to change people are
paying more attention to the linguistic
aspects of how systems are described so
how does one describe the execution
effect what corresponds to this
operational semantics whereby we
specified the behavior of a system by
telling you step-by-step execution well
it's some kind of differential equations
typically maybe stochastic differential
equations but usually ordinary partial
differential equations arising from a
Hamiltonian Lagrangian viewpoint from
which the system description is given
and what corresponds to the abstract
mathematical model that we see in
denotational semantics so this is
perhaps the point at which it becomes
difficult because this is the thing that
doesn't for me at least have a clear
correspondence so what goes here this is
the thing I would actually like to
understand surely there is something
there are indeed mathematical structures
so there's something called the phase
portrait there is there's a whole sort
of geometrical mechanics approach to
describing systems in physics and of
course that is some kind of mathematical
model but it doesn't really look exactly
like denotational semantics it is in
some sense the integrated form of it so
it tells you kind of the phase portrait
that tells you the set of trajectories
of a dynamical system but it would be
interesting to understand in what sense
it corresponds to this
compositional reasoning is actually
becoming important and this we will see
a lot of things about this in the coming
workshop so I won't say anything on this
slide but I will mention some of the I
think key players in this and also type
structure is emerging in the study of
physical systems so we can see this most
notably in work coming out of Oxford
Nijmegen and other places like that ok
so what are the benefits of semantics as
I said
denotational semantics gives a
compositional account of program
behavior which means there's some
mathematical object which has its own
algebra and the algebra of those
mathematical objects somehow mimics the
structural properties of how programs
are put together to take the simplest
example of this if you look at ordinary
sequential programs they compute
functions of some kind functions have a
simple algebraic structure you can
compose them that's the basic operation
for combining functions and this indeed
corresponds to composing programs so the
mathematical algebra sort of mimics
what's happening in the syntactic world
and in the executional model paying
attention to issues of formal semantics
leads to all kinds of new ideas and new
construct so it wasn't just making sense
of very simple elementary programs it
actually stimulated a whole bunch of new
ideas in particular thinking about
higher types people started worrying
about things like substitution they
noticed the formalism invented by
logicians called the lambda calculus the
lambda calculus led naturally to higher
type computation and then indeed this
got absorbed into the programming world
so higher type computation is something
we routinely teach undergraduates now
recursive types became fundamentally
important we realized things like lists
trees and so on came with inductive
definitions but also there are Co
inductive structures like lazy lists
that that people realize became
important things like continuations and
monads that i don't want to talk about
but just to give you some feeling that
that research is alive and well and
continues
in this area importantly a compositional
theory allows one to reason about open
systems so one of the major important
recent results in semantics free beats
now 15 years old is more like 20 is the
work on game semantics done by several
people who are here Samson and rather
and Pasquale malik re as well as
highland on and some others developed
this this subject now this allowed them
to give nice semantics for higher type
programming languages and ultimately
verification of open systems was
actually done and implemented by various
people using this these ideas from game
semantics so this is an important
practical contribution of game semantics
powerful organizing framework for
compositional thinking is category
theory and if you look at what category
theory is about after you you know get
past the arrows and things like that you
realize what is it telling you about
it's giving you putting as the essence
of it is telling you how to compose
morphisms okay you plug together
morphisms it's an important
compositional framework and also it's
giving you things about type structure
because it tells you you can't just
compose any old things you feel like
they have to match up in some way so
both these ideas types and compositions
are right there built into category
theory indeed one can say that type
theory and category theory are simply
two different ways of thinking about the
same thing and we have now seen category
theory emerging in all kinds of settings
even in physics related things so
compositionality in physics so of course
physicists have long been concerned with
putting systems together and one of the
big departures between classical and
quantum physics there were many but one
important departure was how do you put
systems together and people realize that
the important difference is that you use
the tensor product
to combine the state space of quantum
systems rather than the Cartesian
product and this is what leads to many
important insights that ultimately led
to quantum computing okay so this was
already all ways an important feature if
you look at things like quantum field
theory they think about interaction
essentially by introducing what are
called couplings so if you looked at one
of the most successful early quantum
field theories namely quantum
electrodynamics what happens you have a
theory of photons that don't interact
with anything then you have a theory of
electrons which also don't interact with
anything so these are called free field
theories and they're blissfully unaware
of each other and then you start putting
them together by introducing what's
called a coupling this of course makes
what was originally a nice system of
linear differential equations into non
linear coupled differential equations
and now you have this this picture of an
interaction term that takes these two
system that actually combines them and
makes them interact this is actually a
nasty thing in the sense that working
with this combined system is much much
more complicated than simply doing some
kind of salvation you have to do
something much more complex you and
indeed I think it's fair to say we don't
really know how to do it we only know
how to approximate it so the the
approximation Theory says roughly goes
like this you say let's assume that the
fields don't interact then you say okay
let's assume they interact a little bit
and then you say let's assume they
interact so to speak twice as much and
and so you develop a thing called a
perturbation series that tells you the
strength of not so much the strength of
the coupling but the degree of
interaction increases more and more so
you keep track of these interactions how
do you keep track of this kind of
perturbation series it turns out a
diagrammatic framework developed by
Fineman became extremely popular
so Fineman was not the first one to do
these perturbative calculations that was
done by julian schwinger and he wrote
these awesome daunting papers that
nobody could read except possibly
Fineman and and people are actually a
bit shocked when Fineman came up with
this simple
dramatic prescription to think about the
perturbation series and then people
saying on how anybody can calculate
these things that only showing they
could do before so this was you see just
a change in language but instead of
these frightful integrals going across
the page you now have nice pictures and
what was nice about these pictures you
can actually glue them together and get
more complex pictures and you actually
had whoops update no don't install a lot
of 80 so I think here is a case where
worrying about the formalism in which
you are expressing your results actually
became important and the nature in fact
when I was in graduate school I remember
reading a set of lecture notes by felt
man called diagram R which is all about
you know how to keep track of diagrams
in things like gauge theories so people
started going away from this is just
physics do we're actually looking at the
framework for expressing these things as
I said categories are emerging as a way
to think about composing physical
systems and many people here are
involved in that so I can't possibly
mention everyone but I will mention at
least the categorical quantum mechanics
which began with a paper by a Bronski
and cooker in Lix 2004 and then they've
been work by Peter Salinger on a
compositional semantics for quantum
programming languages alex Kissinger has
developed a framework for diagrammatic
reasoning and others
Ross Duncan and so on many other people
have built down this quite categorical
quantum mechanics framework which is
aimed at giving a compositional picture
but many other things also so you will
hear talks by John Byers and Brendan
Brendan here Brendan on combining all
kinds of other systems Markov processes
circuits linear systems Fineman diagrams
networks all these things are all about
taking systems and building more complex
entities out of them especially network
theory one
and say that is the general theory of
how to combine systems and this has been
greatly informed and enriched by a
categorical view okay so that's a you
know propaganda I'm not actually going
to say a little bit about how semantics
is articulated in programming languages
so this part is straight exposition of
you know the first 15 minutes of a
lecture on on denotational semantics
that one might give in a lecture course
and this is sort of will I hope
naturally segue into Gordon's talk
following so what do we do when we look
at the semantics of programming
languages specifically we view programs
as inductively defined terms ok so
there's some kind of induction inductors
formalism like for grammars or something
like that it tells you what the programs
are and just by way of example I thought
I would do a simple but during complete
language so this language has a few
different types it's very primitive
so it has arithmetic expressions it has
boolean expressions and I haven't
bothered to write down the syntax of
those things we just assume that there's
something or the other fairly natural
but then we have the things that
actually do things commands that talk
about the execution of something that is
dynamic so these commands are written
like this so this peculiar thing with
the double colon and the double equal
sign means think of this as an inductive
definition of this set of things so you
can start out with some kind of base
case and once you have some commands you
can build new commands by combining them
with this operator the semicolon that
you have some commands and you have a
boolean expression you can build a new
command doing that so you start building
more and more complex commands
inductively all right so this this is
supposed to be the assignment statement
which tells you that the variable X gets
the result of the of evaluating this
arithmetic expression and of course
this is the familiar if-then-else and
that's the familiar while loop I could
write down semantics for these things
but I won't do that
so what I just want to tell you the type
of semantics so the important thing in
this kind of programming language is
that running a program causes the state
to change okay and what is the state
here so this is the crudest form of
state it gets more and more
sophisticated when you talk about
pointers and locations and things like
that but at the very crudest primitive
level you can just think of a state as a
map from variables to values so of
course there might in principle be
infinitely many different variables but
only finitely many are actually used in
a given program so let's say we're only
looking at the variables that have been
declared in in advance so it's a map
from variables to values so this keeps
out all kinds of structuring things that
one puts in a more realistic language
but what is a command it's simply a
transformer of these states and it's
interpreted and I emphasize this word
interpreted because this is the meaning
of semantics as a partial function from
States to States quite partial because
once one has introduced iteration like
that it is possible to have programs
that don't terminate for example while
true do nothing will not terminate okay
so it might well be that executing a
command in a given state will never
return in a return any kind of result so
you actually have partial functions what
partial functions actually have nice
have a nice algebra so here are these so
maybe this is the most important thing
I'm going to show you the semantics
bracket and this is used to kind of
insulate the syntax from the
mathematical world so just to make sure
they kept really well apart we put these
double lines around it so this notation
means the interpretation of this command
is a partial function so you see I only
have half the arrow that's to signify
partial function from state to state and
of course partial functions
from States to states can be composed
and so you get an algebra of these
mathematical objects how does that
relate to the actual syntactic algebra
so to speak of the text so the point is
this thing can be defined
compositionality compositionally so in
particular this means if I know the
partial functions for the individual
commands that make up a more complex
command I can get the partial function
for the composite entity and I can do
that in all these cases so for example
if I have this thing called sequential
composition which intuitively means you
run this command and when it finishes
you run the next command that is modeled
by this so now C 2 inside this bracket
means a function and C 1 also means a
partial function and now I'm doing
partial function composition here so
this mathematical operation faithfully
mimics that syntactic way of combining
programs all right and one can similarly
do it for this and for that and with a
bit more syntactic gymnastics one can
explain the basic atomic actions as well
so this is the miracle that it can
actually be done compositional
compositionally now if you try to do
this in a purely operational way talking
about step-by-step you can pretty much
do everything compositionally as well
until you come here and here what I mean
is you would like to say the execution
of a while loop is understood completely
by knowing the execution of its body and
the evaluation of this boolean
expression if you try to do this step by
step you have to say well if the boolean
expression is false you're done if the
boolean expression is true then you run
the body that's based on understanding
that substructure but then what do you
do well you run the command again the
whole while loop and this means it's not
any longer a substructure of the piece
that I had so this is where it becomes a
bit more tricky than you might otherwise
think to give these things
compositionally and it turns out that
the the right way to do this is to start
thinking in terms of fixed point theory
okay so even in this very simple
language but needs to invoke fixed point
theory one needs to have some
mathematical idea of when one is
guaranteed to have fixed points existing
and so on and this leads one into the
theory of topology and order and I think
I'm almost done so let me try and
explain the difference between
operational and denotational semantics
so the operational semantics is an
explicit step-by-step description of
execution as state changes as I said
it's not really possible to do this
completely compositionally though the
pioneering work of Gordon Plotkin on
structural operational semantics almost
got us there and and gave us a very nice
format for doing it but even there
things like iteration and recursion
can't quite be done so it can be made
close to compositional but iteration
recursion and a few other things cannot
be given in a strictly compositional way
you have to if you really want a really
inductive definition you must invoke
some idea like fixed point theory
so denotational semantics uses exactly
this kind of mathematical model of
programs as functions but as I said
already in this almost trivial language
order and topology become essential
ingredients in understanding how it
works
once you have that you can give a
completely compositional semantics now
okay you've got this picture of the
program in execution given explicitly
you realize that you want a purely
compositional understanding so that you
can reason about programs and this by
the way is one of the important things
about having a semantics
it means the programmer does not have to
run the program in his or her head if
they could do that we probably wouldn't
need to build computers so we want an
alternative way to think about it and
that alternative way is precisely
through fixed boy theory this by the way
is how I even try to teach my first-year
students to write recursive programs
don't think about runtime stacks and
things I think the fixed-point way I
don't I don't use that phrase but apart
from that this is indeed how I teach
them
who shall question then is yes so you've
got this mathematical model you've got
orders to apologies fix points and so on
and then you've got this concrete
picture why should I believe that your
mathematical science fiction actually
corresponds to what's happening when you
run the program the operational pictures
are other clothes and one can really
readily see how this maps onto a
concrete machine model but the
mathematical picture may be less so so
that's because brave souls go out there
and prove hard correspondence theorems
between these two types of semantics so
these are theorems like adequacy and
full abstraction I won't describe these
things but this is just to give you a
feeling for there are non-trivial rather
difficult theorems challenging results
that one has to prove to certify that
the mathematical semantics and the
operational semantics really match up
appropriately and now by sheer
coincidence
the next speaker will talk about exactly
these two things that I mentioned at the
bottom of the slide so I'll stop here
and leave it open for questions
[Applause]
so we're preparing the YouTuber and
physics you've had operational semantics
lined up next to differential equations
right if one is lucky those differential
equations can be reformulated as a
sensible stationary accent and
intuitively to me that starts to look
somewhat more analogous to the
rotational semantics it's an analogy
I've also thought about things like that
to me the phase portrait which is the
integrated form of the differential
equations is what strikes me as the
analog of the denotational semantics but
then I don't really know how to take one
phase portrait and plug it into another
one so I don't have a clear picture of
how one understands systems
compositionally that way you had your
hand up to time has marched on Jamie
precise way to describe the difference
between operational semantics and
sanitation semantics or is it ultimately
subjective right how can I hunt on this
one
so when one is talking about sequential
programming languages I think it's
fairly clear but when one gets to things
like concurrency and parallelism and so
on then a lot of the things in
denotational semantics looks look like
they're coding up execution steps so for
example one of the things I've worked on
is non-deterministic dataflow
programming and then the denotational
semantics are these sequences of actions
which there are a denotational you have
a mathematical description you do have
an algebraic way of composing them but
they start looking more operational and
or intentional in character but Sampson
is dying to say something
so at least there is some kind of
mathematical space yes with operational
semantics so it's just the text of the
program and the step so everything is
balanced just internally right Prakash
this differential equation example yes
so what happens in physics I think is
not a perfect analogy far from it in
fact the relation to tell you right but
I think Jaime wants some a priori
distinction between these two worlds yes
I your first while mentor Bob always
told me he never understood the
difference I think there is a clear
distinction
it might get murky sometimes but I think
there's a clear distinction that Samson
explained there's a real mathematical
space here but sometimes even that
mathematical space starts looking very
intentional yes Paul section between
continuum and discrete no you can have
discrete continuous either way
so Dominic Dominic had a last question I
think Italian physicists has unified all
of the equations of physics into this
diagrams I was one have never heard of
it
I've heard of it never heard of it
no sounds fascinating so yeah but
possibly we should stop now right
[Applause]